franchise and the city what are the  emotions from that temple just of  leaving that stuff behind  oh man it's tough man it wasn't  something that will stay with me the  rest of my life because I basically grew  up there in Oklahoma City  18 17 years old and in Oklahoma City and  the people the organization have never  done me wrong they always stood up for  me and my family and I've always had my  back and I'm very very grateful I don't  take that for granted and like I said  Sam and mr. Benning and coach Brooks  coach Donovan the whole staff everybody  over there they always have my best  interest in I can do nothing but be  thankful and be grateful to what they  did for me they're my family